c'était une très bonne ambiance du new
type de dialogue était une contestation
générale face aux politiques du
gouvernement sont faits poisson c'est
vraiment mais vraiment l'équivalent de
dire on remplit la carte de crédit cette
austérité fait mal au québec seulement
repris le contrôle des finances
publiques dans le but de donner au
québec le contrôle de sa destinée et sa
destinée c'est aujourd'hui mais c'est
également les prochaines générations
on parle beaucoup d'austérité ces jours
ci au québec et on le mentionnait plus
tôt des milliers de personnes ont
manifesté à montréal contre les
politiques du gouvernement couillard
mais quelle est la force de ce mouvement
la mobilisation va-t-elle durer
alors tasha est à toronto daniel était à
ottawa michel est ici à montréal d'un
bonsoir 3 daniel on annonçait le début
de quelque chose au gésu aujourd'hui le
début d'un mouvement social est ce que
c'est ce que vous avez senti écouté à
c'est un mouvement étudiant avant tout
et pour plusieurs raisons je ne pense
pas que ça va lever beaucoup
un parce que le moment est mal choisi à
la proche de la fin des glaces deux
parce que l'objectif celui de
d'austérité est très large et pas
nécessairement mobilisateur pour tous
les étudiants 3 parce qu'encore une fois
des casseurs les experts and eighty
mutation on avait beaucoup de
crédibilité aux mouvements et est
quatrième
l'impression qu'on a beaucoup surestimé
la volonté des étudiants de descendre
dans la rue
des exemples dans l'outaouais où la
mobilisation était très forte en 2012
tant au cégep et à l'université du
québec dans l'outaouais n'a voté contre
la grève à plus de 60% cégep beauce
appalaches compte à grève à 92%
s'échappe garneau à québec consacré 20
58% devrait continuer encore très long
mouvement car montréal est peut-être
encore plus parler en ce moment de
noticias mme délirant michel on n'est
vraiment pas du tout dans ce qui s'est
passé en 2012 ça se compare pas non on
est très loin et même les étudiants
en 2012 ils avaient fait bloc alors que
là on le voit il ya pratiquement classe
est qui et qui est dans la rue mais la
principale différence je pense c'est que
l'opinion publique ne suit pas d'abord
ça fait à peine un an lac le
gouvernement couillard a été élue la
dernière fois en 2012 le gouvernement
charest avait 9 ans et le mécontentement
c'était avec sédimenter je peux dire et
l'autre la finalité de la grève est pas
clair non plus à l'époque en 2012 on
comprenait très bien on voulait annuler
la hausse des frais de scolarité
maintenant d'austérité ça ressemble à
une bataille contre des moulins à vent à
quel moment la grève peut-elle être
gagné le gouvernement est majoritaire il
y aura pas d'élections avant trois ans
et demi il refera pas son budget demain
matin alors on voit pas du tout comment
ça peut aboutir et et d'autre part et je
pense que c'est peut-être là le plus
important
voyez le manifeste des lucides dans dix
ans cette année la semaine fait ce qui
avait été signé par lucien bouchard et
d'autre et je pense que ce discours là
année après année au fil du temps a
pénétré les esprits et aujourd'hui je
pense qu'une bonne partie de l'opinion
publique qui a acheté le discours du
gouvernement selon lequel il faut vivre
selon nos moyens qu'on a plus les moyens
de se payer les programmes au niveau où
il était est traditionnellement la haie
et même l'opposition ce terrain
politique il
la caq trouve même que le gouvernement
va pas assez loin et même le pq refuse
de remettre en question de l'échéance et
budgétaires alors c'est loin de ce qu'on
a vu en 2012 j'étais vous résignez on ne
sait pas mais en tout cas d'achat les
étudiants souhaitent souhaité en tout
cas un arrimage avec les syndicats vous
étiez à québec pour cette journée de
réflexion sur la grève dans le secteur
public une journée une grande journée de
réflexion les syndicats pour le moment
où sont plutôt opté pour la discussion
oui il y avait des syndicats qui ont
marché un décès de gamme en chine
aujourd'hui à contribuer à la marche
avec les étudiants mais en général
l'attitude je pense de la dalle
direction des syndicats du cos et les
potes de s'allier immédiatement avec les
étudiantes et les étudiants qui veulent
s'allier avec les syndicats qui vont
permettre la grève générale illimitée
qu'ils souhaitent
jusqu'à l'automne où les syndicats dont
le front commun serait en mesure de
faire une grève générale si les
négociations sont échoués à ce moment là
mais je pense de ce qu'on voit c'est ce
que j'ai vu c'est que oui c'est une très
forte je pense esprits pour la grève
parmi les délégués qui étaient présents
à cette journée de réflexion mais que la
direction est un peu plus conservateur
dans son approche et aimerait bien
négocier parce que justement c'est pas
qu'ils acceptent le discours des lucides
mais je pense que tout le monde
considère que le gouvernement fait face
à une énorme dette 275 milliards de
dollars 11 milliards $ par année qui
sont défense est beau pour servir à
cette dette
l'argent n'est pas là pour donner le
type d'augmentation que souhaitent les
syndicats
daniel est ce que c'est un repli
stratégique de la part des syndicats ne
pas se joindre aux étudiants en tout cas
pas maintenant avait-il le choix
oui j'avais le choix ils savaient le
choix ils auraient très bien pu pistonné
les étudiants comme il l'avait fait en
il aurait très bien pu s'impliquer
davantage on les a vus un peu
aujourd'hui mais pas énormément
est ce qu'ils sont capables à l'automne
de mobiliser tout ce beau monde il
faudra voir tâche à bien de dire ah
parce que bon attendons-nous michel
décrivait ce matin dans le devoir
il y aura probablement pas d'entente
négociée ça va se terminer en levant
spéciale à moins d'un miracle
et si vous croyez au mérite donc est-ce
que sk l'automne les syndicats seront
capables de mobiliser leurs propres
membres il me semble pas y avoir un
appétit débordant pour une pour une
grève générale
est ce que le front commun sont son
unité sera maintenu c'est plusieurs
questions qu'il faut se poser et si les
syndicats réussisse à convaincre tout ce
beau monde descend dans la rue est ce
que les étudiants vont en boîte il pas
ce sera peut être plus facile pour voir
ce qu'on a la passion en cause peut-être
plus précises d'un objectif peut être
plus précis mais il faudra voir
on nous avait promis un train un premier
temps très très chaud les médias et
c'est un peu leur faute dont beaucoup
véhiculer cette idée là pour l'instant
on n'en est pas là on nous promet un
automne de tous les bouleversements à
attendre un peu avant d'aller jusque-là
sage sans doute michel le gouvernement a
aussi mis de la pression cette semaine
sont les universités le ministre
françois blais qui suggérait assez de
façon assez maladroite des quotas
d'expulsion même pour mettre fin au
grabuge malhabile quand même oui ben oui
on passait que ce genre de déclaration
là c'était fini avec le départ de
monsieur bolduc
mais de toute évidence monsieur blé
c'est contagieux disons cette tendance à
la pop
non c'est vraiment malade doit cesser le
vieil adage pendant 11 ans quelques-uns
pour faire peur aux autres dans les
circonstances étaient vraiment pas
nécessaire en plus sur le mouvement
s'essoufflait et d'autre part il y avait
des injonctions qui avait été demandée
qui ont finalement été accordé c'est de
la provocation inutile en tout cas ça a
été perçu comme ça même si c'était
peut-être pas l'intention de monsieur
blé non à tous ces gars là vraiment
c'est une gaffe tâche a pas juste pas
certaine mais je pense que le
gouvernement se sent très confiant et
pense que comme tu as dit michel la
population n'est pas là elle n'est pas
enthousiaste comme elle était en 2012
quand il y avait vraiment quelque chose
de précis pour les étudiants pourquoi
lutter et aussi je pensais à ce moment
là vraiment c'était aussi le fait que le
gouvernement avait imposé la loi 78 sur
les manifestations qui est vraiment fait
déborder la vase populaire maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est c'est beaucoup plus
vague et oui je pense le gouvernement
devrait pas provoquer mais en même temps
je pense qu'il faut la main forte le
gouvernement sur le budget et aussi sur
les étudiants parce qu'il veut pas une
répétition justement mais c'est vrai
mais là c'est la ces se réunit en fin de
semaine il ya une forte tendance en tout
cas à vouloir
faire à tout le moins une pause alors si
t'as pas de moment de donner des
munitions je pense à elle la plus
radicale du mouvement alors
stratégiquement je pense c'était
maladroit penser que ses amis de lui sur
le ca pourrait mettre wissembourg est
certainement bon ça ressemble quand même
à un faux départ tout ça est ce que
malgré les compressions qui sont quand
même importante par le gouvernement
lorsque ça veut dire que le gouvernement
couillard a gagné la première manche
daniel ben si on veut si on veut parler
de gagnants et perdants si vous trouvez
un gagnant c'est le gouvernement
plusieurs fois nécessairement parce que
bon les labos organisations étudiantes
ou la mobilisation syndicale ne lève pas
autant qu'on avait pensé qu'elle
pourrait lever mais parce que le
gouvernement accueillir jusqu'à
maintenant
malgré une tonne de faux pas et françois
blais l'a encore illustré ce jour
dernier malgré une tonne de faux-pas
maintient le cap n'a pas l'intention de
reculer
on l'a vu dans le budget ça va être
encore plusieurs l'an prochain il faut
il faut regarder un peu comment
fonctionne ce gouvernement là c'est
essentiellement deux ministres très fort
qui mène cette bataille l'homme à 3,2 et
gaétan barrette et ce sont deux pitbulls
qui ne vont pas reculer donc est ce que
le gouvernement couillard a gagné la
première manche si vous trouvez un
gagnant ma réponse est oui a gagné la
première manche michel
oui je pars d'écouté faisons de
comparaison c'est avec 2003 15
gouvernement charest est arrivé lui
aussi avec des intentions de rien généré
sap a pris six mois et tout ça avait été
remisé sur les tablettes
là on verra comment ça finira exactement
sur le plan comptable à la fin de
l'année mais le déficit zéro il est
atteint à toutes fins utiles alors dû le
gouvernement peut certainement dire
qu'il a atteint son objectif et c'est
vrai qu'il ya des pitbulls dans ce
gouvernement là mais vous savez en 2003
il y avait mené que jérôme forget qui
est qui avait la tête dure elle aussi et
qui a dû reculer et une des différences
je pense c'est que jusqu'à présent tout
cas le premier laisse couillard est
solidement derrière ses ministres alors
qu'en 2003 la pression monte à ces
messieurs charest qui avait donné le
signal du public
monsieur criard qui célébrera son
premier anniversaire le 1er anniversaire
son gouvernement mardi
j'aimerais qu'on parle de tahoua un peu
le procès du sénateur déchu mcdo fille
qui doit commencer aussi mardi prochain
certains parlent du procès politique de
la décennie tâche est quand même rare
qu'un chef de cabinet la premier
ministre témoigne sous serment il faut
s'attendre à de nouvelles révélations
parce qu'on a un peu l'impression qu'on
sait à peu près tout sur ce qui s'est
passé mais les attentes sont très haute
ce qui veut dire que si elles ne sont
pas atteints que les gens vont dire que
ce n'est pas intéressant ce procès là et
je pense que c'est celle d'angers pour
ceux qui comptent sur ce procès pour
faire renverser le gouvernement mais
détruire leurs chances d'être réélu en
octobre et je pense que le gouvernement
le sait un peu aussi le procès de
monsieur d'office ça va prendre des
semaines
des mois peut-être et on va voir que y
avait non seulement d un jour oui mais
c'est ça mais si on sait on sait pas
aussi s'y est toujours des suspensions
et des choses de ce genre mais les
témoins c'est pas tout ce qu'ils vont
être appelés ça va être aussi un peu
plate au début il ya des preuves qui
doivent être déposées c'est seulement
s'il ya quelque chose vraiment qu'il vit
monsieur harper je pense à la sphère qui
explosif que c'est exactement différence
oui et le gouvernement s'est déjà ils
ont dit qu'ils vont déposer budget le 21
il est des choses qui peuvent contrer ça
dans les médias pour que les vidéos ont
autre chose sur quoi fixer au lieu de
juste le procès daniel écoutez moi je
pense que la crise se profilait chesney
joe wright l'ancien chef de cabinet de
stephen saison non et c'est lui qui a
réponse à peu près à toutes les
questions souvenez vous un moment donné
il avait premier ministre avait admis à
thomas mulcair du npd que oui il ya un
courriel dans lequel on a maintenant le
ok du premier ministre loki pour moi
exactement si benoît pelosse jamais et
tu y mets en cours ils devront
probablement lui dire tout tourne autour
de lui la grande question qu'on se pose
en ce moment c'est comment il se fait
que tu as faits est accusé d'avoir
obtenu pots-de-vin ou d'avoir corrompu
un fonctionnaire pour 90 mille dollars
et que le fonctionnaire un autre côté
n'est pas accusé du tout cas fallait pas
plus aujourd'hui qu'on crie à la
collusion ou à l implication politique
qu'on cherche des scandales un peu
partout sauf que il ya des questions à
poser là dessus et le témoignage nigel
wright à mon avis on va faire en sorte
sauf et sera acquittée au condamné
alors michel d'après vous ça peut
éclaboussé stephen harper ou faudrait
qu'il ya quelque chose de bureau pour
éclabousser monsieur un peu parce que
j'ai l'impression que les gens
d'abord ça très bien que sur un peu et
un contrôleur compulsif et qu'il y avait
les deux mains dans les personnes qui
pensent que monsieur harper l'a été pour
rien dans toute cette histoire là et à
partir de ce moment là je pense le
dommage qui avait à être causés au
gouvernement a déjà été dans une très
large mesure alors s'il n'y a pas
quelque chose de particulièrement
sordide qui sort et que c'est simplement
la confirmation des soupçons que tout le
monde avait je pense que ça va être
gérable et et d'autre part ça c'est un
processus biais du che je comprends
qu'on veut avoir des témoignages dans
les journaux continuellement mais je
pense pas que l'opposition est monsieur
moto en particulier va pouvoir refaire
le coup de la dernière fois et revenir
jour après jour monsieur monsieur à prix
modiques tcc devant la cour on peut pas
parler
alors nous on aura l'occasion de s'en
reparler certainement puisque vous
l'avez dit ça va être non alors je vous
remercie beaucoup tous les trois on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine merci et
au revoir